je suis très bien écrit je ne pouvais
pas être mieux
pendant des décennies jean vanille à
cacher une part obscure de son existence
ou l'accompagnement spirituel se
transformer en abus de confiance et en
relation sexuelle coercitives non
consentante profonde tristesse profonde
déception des vagues de colère des vague
d'incompréhension
les membres de la communauté de l'arche
comme elisabeth richard qui ont donné
des années de leur vie à l'organisme
sont en état de choc
et pour cause de nationalité canadienne
jean vanier a créé dans les années 60
avec l'appui de son mentor le père
thomas philippe la première communauté
de l'arche dédié aux personnes qui
vivent avec un handicap intellectuel
aujourd'hui cette enquête jette une
ombre et des soupçons sur les fondateurs
de l'entreprise c'est à dire que tout ce
qu'on aurait pu imaginer sans doute
qu'on s'attendait
c'est que j'en savais peut-être par
rapport au père thomas cette enquête
troublante démontre que le père thomas
l'ami de jean vanier était au coeur d'un
graves scandales d'agressions sexuelles
et contrairement à ce qu'il a toujours
prétendu jean vanier était parfaitement
au courant maintenant à vue le rapport
[Musique]
chacun on est abasourdi et ce qui
bouleverse louis pilonnent qui travailla
large depuis 40 ans c'est que non
seulement jean vanier connaissait les
déviances du père thomas depuis les
années 50 mais il adopter au fil du
temps un comportement semblable
je sens que l'arche a été trahi comme
organisation dans ce rapport six
victimes présumées qui ne sont pas des
personnes handicapées ont témoigné des
agissements de jean vanier
l'accompagnement spirituel s'est
transformée en touché sexuelle cela a
duré trois ou quatre ans chaque fois
j'étais figé j'étais incapable de
distinguer ce qui était bien et ce qui
était mal
c'était très intime et il a tout fait
sauf la pénétration intentions d'un
homme que j'ai moi personnellement tant
aimé et admiré une part de moi qui
pouvais pas y croire fait bien sûr
demain profonde profonde tristesse le
choc de la nouvelle sera terrible pour
les communautés de l'arche qui dépendent
de la générosité des donateurs
l'organisme survivra-t-il à la trahison
de ses fondateurs genre il a démarré sa
vie la fronde est sain il a eu cette
intuition là mais le modèle c'est
l'expérience super jambes
n'empêche si jean vanille était perçu
comme cet homme c'est un visage
méconnaissable que nous fait découvrir
cette enquête
alain crevier radio canada québec